alles nur politisch stimmt das so
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit pedro
vom bund deutscher kriminalbeamter guten
abend schön dass sie da sind wir haben
es gehört das ist zündstoff diese neue
allianz was sagen sie dazu was waren
ihre ersten gefühle und empfindungen
heute morgen
na ja im grunde genommen also entgegen
dem was jetzt eben beitrag geteilt
worden ist aus unserer sicht das ist
nicht neu ist dass wir hier unter
verknüpfungen zu leiten haben zwischen
den angehörigen kriminelle clans und
rocker kriminelle rockergruppierungen
also wir sollten das jetzt nicht
unbedingt als brandneu empfinden wir
hatten schon in der vergangenheit
beerdigungen von angehörigen von klaren
familien wo eben auch angehörige
kriminelle rockergruppierungen anwesend
waren wir wissen schon aus verschiedenen
lager bildern dass es dort
schnittstellen gibt und letztlich ist
das eine sache die darin begründet ist
dass man hier gemeinsame geschäfte
machen möchte und das auch im
kriminellen bereich und da gibt es
synergieeffekte wie das auch in einem
wirtschaftsunternehmen ist und insofern
ist das jetzt für uns oder für mich
jetzt keine große neuigkeit
früher gab es diese kredite dieses
klischee dass die hells angels dass das
ja irgendwelche deutschen drucker oder
sowas sind heute wissen wir viele von
denen haben selbst migrationshintergrund
spielt das auch eine rolle sind hier
leute miteinander verwandt gibt es der
alte netzwerke in die heimat wissen sie
da was über also wir sollten nicht
darüber spekulieren was gegenstand der
ermittlungen und auch dass personen
umfeldes der ermittlungen in berlin sind
die kenne ich auch gar nichts auch nicht
meine aufgabe aber letztlich die sind
hierbei die hälfte
essentials haben ihre in ihrer uhr regel
im grunde schon drin dass zum beispiel
keine dunkelhäutigen menschen
aufgenommen werden dürfen also
ursprünglich war das ja mal eine
vereinigung die letztlich doch sehr
archaische grundlagen hatte so wie das
jetzt auch bei den kleinen familien der
fall ist und wir haben im grunde
genommen seit mehreren jahren durch das
die zu kommen immer mehr bei den hells
angels auseinandersetzung bald zum
beispiel türkischstämmige mitglieder
dann aufgenommen werden die wiederum mit
den sogenannten old school an konflikten
als wir kennen das ja ist eine bewegung
die letztlich schon länger beobachtet
werden kann auf der anderen seite sind
was die bekannten straftaten angeht und
die daran beteiligten beschuldigten ist
eben die deutsche nationalität nachdem
lage bildern die uns vorliegen hier
führend also der größte anteil der
bekannt gewordenen straftäter sowohl im
bereich der kleinkriminalität als auch
der rocker kriminalität ist eben zu
einem ganz erheblichen teil auch mit der
deutschen staatsbürgerschaft
ausgestattet das muss man immer wieder
sich in erinnerung rufen
jetzt sprechen sie gerade über die
kriminalität wie gefährlich ist jetzt
diese allianz von rockern und
kleinfamilien er ist eine sehr
gefährliche allen ganz wollen sie im
grunde genommen auf ihre in der wirkung
auch gegenüber jetzt zeugen und zeugen
gegenüber anderen verfahrensbeteiligten
auch der öffentlichkeit eben durch ihre
bekanntheit auch als kriminelle
organisationen eben auch dafür sorge
tragen dass zb ein ermittlungsverfahren
hier keinerlei zeugenaussagen zu
erhalten sind weil zeugen massiv bedroht
werden die möglicherweise auch eine
aussage machen wollen das system sowohl
krimineller familienclans als auch der
kriminellen rockergruppierung beruht ja
darauf dass man sich abschottet dass man
das deutsche rechtssystem ablehnt und
dass man hier auch eine art von parallel
justiz bemüht die eben auch
gekennzeichnet ist dass man nicht mit
verfolgungsbehörden zusammenarbeitet
dass man keine angaben gegenüber der
polizei macht dass man das intern regelt
und das kennen wir sowohl von den hells
angels als auch kennen wir das von
kriminellen familienclans
mehr nachrichten und welches nur weil
die schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren